leur nom et leur destination autour du
cou quelques effets dans un baluchon ses
enfants quittent leur village du
Territoire de Belfort pour rejoindre la
Suisse en camion carriole ou à pied il
fuit la famille et les bombardements qui
se rapprochent
entre la libération de Besançon et la
libération de Belfort Montbéliard il y a
eu quand même plusieurs mois de bagarres
du côté du Lomont
donc on partait on était content de
partir de quitter tout ça
accueilli dans des familles suisses à
les maniques ou romande rhabillées et
bien nourris les petits frontois
découvrent une forme d'opulence après
des années de privation en France on
traverse
on prenait des bains c'était dans une
bassine dans le à la cuisine
alors que là-bas il y avait déjà une
salle de bain il y avait des choses qui
m'étonnaient il y avait des grands
magasins avec des escaliers esclamateurs
comme ça comme on rencontre dans tous
les grands magasins maintenant
et ça sentait bon ça sentait les jouets
ce transfert de centaines d'enfants à
travers la frontière s'est fait par la
Croix-Rouge grâce à la mobilisation et
au tractations de la famille velar de
Morvillars en France et leurs amis et
parents la famille bourrus à Boncourt en
Suisse une grande fierté pour leur
descendants qui incarne ses personnages
dans leurs habits d'époque
les efforts qu'on fait
ma famille pour sauver 15.000 enfants
c'est c'est une ville c'est un effort
formidable n'est-ce pas ont souvent on
regarde des commémorations et c'est
beaucoup mieux de les vivre même si on
le fait maladroitement il y avait des
imprécisions il y avait aussi c'était un
peu un peu grotesque parfois
néanmoins c'était vrai sans être précis
c'était vrai
une véracité portée par les
reconstituteurs de l'association
souvenirs et amitié renforcé par des
collectionneurs alsaciens s'ils ont
l'habitude de raconter les combats et la
libération ils étaient heureux de mettre
aussi en lumière cette année cet épisode
peu connu de solidarité des Suisses avec
les petits français